prenez ce tu as caché 41 ans je suis
conseiller départemental du canton 4
septembre est un qui regroupe la commune
de sainte-suzanne lé quartier de
cambuston et le petit oiseau
je suis avant tout un oui et en
politique un militant associatif engagée
depuis de longue date
dans le cadre de l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des familles il faut
savoir que je côtoie je connais les
problématiques de mon canton et je
côtoie les acteurs du monde associatif
et du monde social
avec la mine au jeu dira roumanie et
puis nous ne remplaçons bien bien a
battu nice à callicanes vie je vais
mettre l'accent sur plus sur plusieurs
thèmes qui vont engager l'avenir de
notre canton des thèmes tels que de
sociales la famille la culture le sport
ainsi comme projet nous avons dans un
premier temps
d'essayer de travailler faut trouver une
solution à la problématique des constate
décès parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que lorsqu'on que ça décède les
week-ends et jours fériés c'est vraiment
un gros problème pour pouvoir avoir un
médecin pour faire ce constat dans le
domaine de l'éducation nous souhaitons
lutter contre la rupture numérique par
la mise à disposition des tablettes pour
les élèves du collège à partir de la
cinquième au niveau du chômage des
jeunes nous souhaitons accentuer
encourager
la mise en place des ateliers de
chantier n'en ciation pour justement
donner un bouffée d'oxygène à cette
jeunesse qui souffre du chômage
et au niveau de l'agriculture
nous souhaitons mettre en place des
retenues collinaires pour que les
agriculteurs de ce canton puisse faire
face à la problématique de la sécheresse
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
conseil départemental occupèrent très
important dans l'aménagement de notre
canton dans l'aménagement de la réunion
il est très important de prendre attache
auprès de cette population qui souffre
d'être à l'écouté pour mettre en place
un nouveau modèle de société un nouveau
projet social pour sentir la réunion de
ce marasme